welcome to this video playing hora bets
from the US let's see what do we get
dibs Oh probably playing one of my bad
lines oops yeah okay can always do that
ok so is playing quickie 5 because 5 now
what about is I see playing eve or maybe
wonder about that you fall
before here maybe d5 study for and I had
this I had this against some some guy
and wasn't trouble nigera maybe it's not
a big deal if he takes out if it takes
the pawn on d4 why typically has very
decent compensation for that but I tell
nigeria's not move I generally want to
lay here trusting I don't want to play
94 though so fairly normal in this sound
at least at some something you can play
takes takes gives my bishop a pretty
good position on your form
very complicated position not sure what
black should do it sound okay there are
two two questions that i have is 96 that
bad Queen takes Bishop takes it's hard
to believe that check this should be any
good night xe5 was the second question
but this is probably more convincing I
want to I want yeah I guess here i am
not with the sea porn takes after it
takes I want to have rocky bottom look
you can and how now how to play now
takes Knight takes a four-minute a for
Bishop e3 now
should a through you yeah if you watch
my channel regularly you know that I
have this this bishop pair thing I
always want to have the two bishops here
and you probably can guess that I like
this position how do I continue though
f5 is hanging and c3 as well
hmm
don't know where to go with this Bishop
here very very tricky position not clear
I think maybe if it takes and queen bee
three mi just getting the pawn maybe am
I getting the poem just like that this
is also maybe still to see to heart very
difficult
okay Knight takes Knight takes is a
self-penned maybe not the terrible one
but still the South pen I just got I got
Bishop e7 okay dear Queenie to maybe or
to be three okay one minute forty
shouldn't shouldn't be slow here if
possible bc now let's get funny funny
bishops here on baton on a 20 h three
want to try to get rid of his active
rook here Wow strong strong move
activating the rook
my background is a week unfortunately
consequence of this weird bisha p.m.
taking this night as well
Quincy seven
probably i play Queen a six-hour game 5
okay but anyway I think i irritate my
morning maybe I can tell Bishop d7 now
57 either the rook the rook I'm he's
attacking me okay maybe and then Bishop
d7 night takes I he said that the queen
is protected of course the queen is
protected I first check check
ok so I managed to to get to a to a
drawn to Jack but i'm down on the clock
check check check check check check
check check check
check check check check white forfeits
on challenge just as I'm winning here
yeah it's a typical typical time stuff
what can you do it's a totally wrong ah
yeah of course I shouldn't draw I should
win the game somewhere around here white
is winning but I couldn't put him away
or at least why should be clearly better
it's it's it's simply not only this
stuff King evade and so on but it's a
very difficult position to play that
sets clear and I didn't I didn't play it
well rook be one tough tough Bishop e3
and is it looked like okay maybe Bishop
e3 was mistimed and I should take here
first this is given as a as an advantage
I mean it's a bit frustrating to not win
after a lemon like Bishop f5 which is so
obviously bad check right okay check
this is right but how do I put him away
Brooke be one really chair maybe just
attacking this pawn
that's very difficult to to play in
Illinois seen rook age five Bishop to e4
very tough to blame so this is what I
did it takes and here you can take on 94
94 is good for black yeah I was pretty
sure that there were some mistakes
around yet it's just too complicated but
around here I think I really should be a
should have a good position but i didn't
i didn't manage I'm curious about him
f-35 difficult of the plane my back rank
is really weak Bishop d7 and resins yes
of course yeah the problem that I am I
was just all my queen is attacked and I
need to do something but I'm just
winning here this is of course winning
as all pieces are hanging on the black
side and this is also winning clearly
with the with the pin so i was a topic
okay i went here and he found this good
defense IAM amazing ok and now Bishop d7
is not working at least not chatting
take I a 5v5 is probably better
now yeah this is this is this is
probably better trying to exchange him
on one pawn of course this has already
gone wrong for me okay thanks for
watching